♪ ♪ ♪
pour le populaire humoriste
Philippe Bond. Dans une enquêtee
du quotidien La Presse,
huit femmes témoignent contre
victimes d'inconduites sexuelles
de la part de l'hu
entre 2006 et 2015.
Les allégations des présumées
vérifiées par Radio-Canada.
Il ne fa d'aucune
accusation criminelle.
L'éventa
qu'on lui reproche est vaste.
e des commentaires
déplacés, des touchers
sexuels sans consentement.
issements)
Assurant ne pas vouloir
commenter le cas précis premierr
ministre François Legaulta néan.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
Puis moi, j'invite toutes
les victimes à dénoncer.
Ça a pas de place, en 2022,
dans notre société.
aux allégations en se disant
par ce qu'il a lu,
ne reconnaissant pas la personne
la tempête que sa femme etses e.
Il annoncer quitter la vie
pour ses collaborateurset ses e,
celle de la police de Gatineau,
montrée du doigt par
une présumée victime qui aurait
sans être prise au sérieux,
selon el
RENÉE-ANNE ST-AMANT, Service de
police de la Ville de Gatineau
les personnes qui le veulent
ésenter chez nous
et on pourra repartir
à zéro et prendre la vers
de ce qu'on comprend, a besoind.
Donc, on les invite fortement
à venir nous rencléguée
a justement l'intention
de porter plainte.
LISA MATTHEWS, présumée victime
- Évidemment, jlainte. Prlainte,
je suis en dehors du pays.
Je ne réside plus
au Québec ni au Canada.e revenir
au Québec dans trois semaines
pour conduire ma plainte.
- Le milieu de l'humour fois toé
par un scandale lié à
de l'inconduite sexuelle.
Comment peut-on expliquercurren?
Me SOPHIE GAGNON,
directrice générale, Juripop
- Il y a plusieurs facteurs
exemple, c'est que les rapports
ir sont très présents,
sont très asymétriques.
Il y a très peu de personn salas
ont des contrats, travaillen
à la pige, ce qui fait en sorte
qu'il y a pas d'employeurs
CORALIE LAPERRIÈRE, humoriste
nous dit que
les dénonciations publiques
et anonymes, c'est pas la
police, on se fait pas croire.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
On est dans un cul-de-sac
qu'il faut vraiment discuter.- e
de la vie publique et de
la scène. À les liens
d'affaires avec l'humoriste.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Mon